this is the crash which changed the face
of niki lauda and ultimately made him
the face of sporting courage loud his
car all but destroyed in hospital the
Austrian who suffered severe burns to
his face was read his last rites this is
the podium following the Long Beach
Grand Prix in 1983 former teammate John
Watson saw him being pulled from the
burning wreckage I got him to lie down
and then I kneeled down put his head in
my thighs so I could talk to him and he
was lucid and and communicative but
clearly he'd had you know severe burns
to his face brilliant brave and many
believed indestructible the Austrian
lost most of his right ear but just 40
days later was back racing again
finishing fourth in the Italian Grand
Prix
how does that sit in the pantheon of
sports in comebacks I think it's the
most impressive and most courageous and
moved by any professional sports person
that I've ever met
louder though was determined to retain
his World Championship title especially
against the British driver and
blond-haired heartthrob James Hunt
their rivalry and louder's comeback was
worthy of a Hollywood script and in 2013
found its way onto the silver screen
with the film rush
[Applause]
after his accident louder won the
championship twice more in 1977 and 1984
he was a super race driver Nicky was one
of those guys would always know when he
was on the limit or or if he knew it was
a little bit more there he could find
outside race car driving
louder became a successful businessman
setting up his own airline and even
captaining planes occasionally into 60s
Niki Lauda remained a non-executive
chairman at Mercedes until his death he
was credited with having been
instrumental in bringing Lewis Hamilton
to the team he also acted as a mentor to
many of the drivers ultimately he was
proven mortal but his legacy of bravery
extends far beyond the racetrack Martha
Kellner Sky News